this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Skillshare as a child I was
kind of picky about what I ate but now
I'm an adult I'll happily eat as much
broccoli as you put in front of me why
is that
when did foods I used to hate become
delicious to me and whatever thank tis
might impact how tasty my food is in
this episode all it's fun yeah now part
of why our foods taste the way that they
do is down to our genes and evolution in
fact a child's natural aversion to
bitter foods is actually connected to
how our ancestors survived exactly some
plants evolved toxins to stop animals
like us from eating them so we evolved
to find the tastes of plants bitter to
help stop us from poisoning ourselves
exactly however how things taste isn't
just down to our genes it's also
affected by our age the way that this
works is that over time the cells in our
bodies are constantly dying and being
replaced with new ones and our taste
buds cells are no exception however when
we hit about 40 or 50 years old our
taste buds cells continue to expire but
new ones replaced them at a slower rate
resulting in a reduced sense of taste so
age does impact our taste but not in a
very significant way and not until we're
at least 40 so what other factors are at
play well as it turns out the list of
things that affect our taste is
extensive what is the deal with airplane
food well research has shown that a big
part of the problem is actually the
plane itself the air pressure reduce
humidity and even background noise in a
plane cabin can all reduce our ability
to taste sweet and salty foods still
taste horrible language can have an
impact too it's actually been shown the
giving food a descriptive name can make
it
tastes better tastes Kiner famous and
don't rule out your emotions one study
at a hockey game showed that when fans
were asked to rate flavors of ice cream
those who were happy with their team's
victory were more likely to give a high
rating to a flavor that other fans
enjoyed less it's also been shown that
factors like the environment we eat in
our expectations of quality even things
like the color of the glass we drink
from can all change how things taste but
what about those more long-term changes
to our tastes how did those happen well
it might be down to something called
neuroplasticity the idea that the
structure of our brains can change based
on changes in our environment although I
found be a gross when I first tried it
after drinking it repeatedly often while
hanging out with my friends it's
possible that those two ideas beer and
fun we're friends linked in my brain and
the more I did those two things together
the stronger that connection became and
the more I started to like the taste of
beer in fact it's actually been shown
that if you recall a positive memory
about eating vegetables
it can make a present experience of
eating vegetables more enjoyable and
you'll be more likely to eat a bigger
portion so when it comes to taste
although you can't control everything
about it having positive thoughts about
your food can help to make things more
delicious could still use some salt
naturally if you want to learn how to
make your food taste great there's a
skill show course for that why not check
out this course on how to cut like a
chef or maybe this course on mastering
Indian food which personally has me
salivating just thinking about it the
online learning community skill share
has hundreds of culinary courses to
browse through and if you're one of the
first 500 people to sign up to skill
share using the link in the description
you'll get your first two months for
free which is easily enough time to up
your cooking game and that's all for
today thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you next time bye bye
you